so SpaceX is a response to the history
of space exploration this is my point of
view so one of the magical things about
NASA the National Aeronautics and Space
Administration here in the u.s. is the
administration has stayed about the same
for 50
19:58 what is that 56 years
the reason is Congress had the either
the ignorance or the genius to put a
dozen NASA centers in 12 different for
13 different places around the u.s. and
when you try to close a NASA Center in
Congress people come unglued if you
can't close a NASA Center this is how
people got to the moon when John Kennedy
was shot which was an awful thing any
idea to cancel the moon program was
squashed
as soon as Kennedy was shot we couldn't
not not go as the expression goes so
humans went to the moon space program
existed change the world in a great way
however it made things expensive when
you build rocket engines in Alabama you
and you get the fuel from Utah and you
test them in Mississippi and you then
send them to Florida and control all
that from Texas with some drop testing
done in Cleveland and all sorts of reese
material science resources so on done in
California some flight tests done in the
desert of Arizona when you do all that
you just add cost when you go to SpaceX
the material the stainless steel and the
aluminum come off the train cars it goes
through the factory like this we make
our tanks we make our space frame or
airframe we make our rocket engine bells
we make our we hook up our plumbing it
goes back this way we do the wiring it
gets back on the train car and goes to
either then in Burgh Air Force Base or
Cape Canaveral or some other point
because it's all made in one place but
the way NASA was established in 1958
it's not set up that way and that was
good and bad so it is to be hoped that
SpaceX Sierra Nevada Space blue origins
that these companies will emerge and
lower the cost especially of taking
stuff to low Earth orbit keep in mind
everybody for all the free market
libertarian let's go let a fair people
SpaceX has taken at least half a billion
dollars five hundred million dollars
from NASA because NASA wants to develop
this capability when you buy an Atlas 5
rocket or a delta 4 rocket those are
commercially made gizmos and so is going
to be the Falcon and Falcon Heavy these
are commercial rockets and NASA has gone
to great lengths to develop that
business it's all good it's all good I
would go to space like that I applied to
be an astronaut four times I would love
to get a view of the Earth from space
and right now the price is $200,000
starts to come down into the 10th of
that I could I could imagine doing it if
you've never jumped out of a plane with
a parachute that is cool
I don't do it full-time but I get it
it's exciting and you do see the world
in a new way and you're in the air
everybody's dream is to be able to fly
you're flying for a few moments it's I
get it I can see how people get hooked
on that and I think space exploration
would be the same deal
you